circuit for independent ly measuring the observables is none other than our parity check circuit for the 3-bit
repetition code and so we see that our two equations together are equivalent to the parity check circuit outputting 0 0
which is the syndrome that indicates that no errors have been detected the three Cubit poly operations
ZZ identity and identity ZZ are called stabilizer generators for this code and the stabilizer of the code is the set
generated by the stabilizer generators this set the stabilizer is a fundamentally important mathematical
object associated with this code and we'll discuss further the role that it plays as the lesson continues for now
I'll just point out that we could have made a different choice for the generators for instance we could have selected Z identity Z in place of either
of the generators we did select and the code and the stabilizer would be exactly the same next we'll consider bit flip
detection for the three-bit repetition code with a focus on the interactions and relationships among the poly
operations that are involved namely the stabilizer generators and the errors themselves suppose that we've encoded a
cubit using the three-bit repetition code and a bit flip error occurs on the leftmost Cubit this causes our state side to be
transformed according to the action of an X operation or X error on the leftmost Cubit as we already know we can detect
this error by performing the parody checks for the three-bit repetition code or equivalently we can measure the
encoding non-destructively treating the stabilizer generators as observables let's start with the first
stabilizer generator and see what happens our state has been affected by an X error and we'd like to understand
how the measurement of the stabilizer generator as an observable is influenced by this error x and z anticommute whereas
everything commutes with the identity Matrix and so it follows that ZZ identity anti-c commutes with X identity
identity so we get a minus sign when the order is changed and we also know that ZZ identity doesn't do anything to S
because s is a valid encoding of a cubit and valid encodings are always plus one igen vectors of both stabilizer
generators that leaves us with negative X identity identity applied to S and therefore X identity identity applied to
S is an igen Vector of ZZ identity with igen value negative one we can also do something similar
with the second stabilizer generator but this time the error commutes with the stabilizer generator and so our
Corrupted State is again an igon Vector of the stabilizer generator but this time the igen value is positive
one so our Corrupted State is an IG Vector of both stabilizer generators and whether the igen value is plus one or
minus one is determined by whether the error commutes or anti-c commutes with each stabilizer generator for the first
one the error and the stabilizer generator anticommute and for the second one they commute and it's always going to be one or the other because any two
poly operations either commute or anticommute meanwhile the actual State side doesn't really play an important
role here except for the fact that the stabilizer generators act trivially on this state so when we're thinking about the
detection of Errors we really don't need to concern ourselves with the specific encoded State all that matters is whether the error commutes or anti-c
commutes with each stabilizer generator so let's make a table that has one row for each stabilizer generator
and one column for each error here I've only included the errors corresponding to a single bit flip as
well as no error at all which is indicated by the identity tensed with itself three times we could add more columns for other errors if we wanted
but for now we'll focus on just these errors the entry in the table is either plus one or minus one depending on
whether the error and the stabilizer generator commute or anticommute so for each error in the table we can look at
the corresponding column to see how that error will transform any given encoding into a plus one or a minus one igen
vector of each stabilizer generator these columns correspond precisely to the syndrome we would obtain from the
parity checks which are equivalent to the non-destructive measurements of the stabilizer generators as
observables of course the entes in this table are plus ones and minus ones rather than zeros and ones respectively
and if you prefer you can think about the syndromes as being the corresponding binary strings rather than Columns of plus ones and minus ones but there's a
direct correspondence and just to make the connection between the syndromes and the igen values more clear and direct
I'm going to refer to these vectors of plus ones and minus ones as syndromes as before the syndromes tell
us something about whatever error took place and in particular if we know that one of these four possible errors
occurred the syndrome indicates to us which one it was and we can correct it by applying the error again if we
choose next I'll say just a little bit more about the syndromes and in particular we'll take a closer look at
their algebraic aspects our encodings are three Cubit States so they're unit vectors in an
eight dimensional complex Vector space and what the four possible syndromes do is to slice this eight dimensional space
up into four four two-dimensional subspaces meaning that the vectors in any one of these subspaces will always give us the same
syndrome in more detail this diagram illustrates how the eight-dimensional space is divided
up each stabilizer generator splits the space into two subspaces of equal Dimension namely the space of plus one
IG vectors and the space of minus one I vectors for example the plus one vectors of ZZ identity are linear combinations
of standard basis States for which the leftmost two bits have even parity and the minus one igen vectors are linear
combinations of standard basis States for which the leftmost two bits have odd parity and the situation is similar for
the other stabilizer generator except that it's the rightmost two bits rather than the leftmost two bits so these four subspaces are easy to
describe in this case owing to the fact that this is a very simple code in particular the Subspace
corresponding to the syndrome plus one +1 is is the space spend by C 000000 and K 111 which is the space of valid
encodings and that's called the code space and in general the spaces are spanned by the standard Bas of states
that are shown in the corresponding squares although it's not necessarily as clear or as easy to see the syndromes
also partition all of the three Cubit poly operations which represent the possible poly errors that could take place into four equal siiz collections
depending upon which syndrome that error would cause for example any poly operation
that commutes with both stabilizer generators results in the syndrome plus1 plus1 and among the 64 possible three
Cubit poly operations there are exactly 16 of them in this category including the three that are mentioned on the screen and likewise for the other three